rodrigo una gran carrera tm en pool este
domingo prácticamente sorprendió a
muchos con ese ataque subiendo lo que
era ya una de las simas para llegar a la
meta pero qué podemos esperar de renco y
en líneas generales que fue esta carrera
celebrada el domingo louis realmente ha
sido una carrera espectacular de renco
lo has dicho muy bien tenía muchas dudas
después de aquel grave accidente en
agosto de 2020 y aunque había ganado
ciertas etapas hoy realmente ha ganado
su gran victoria pero no sólo de este
año de toda su corta carrera profesional
y ha despejado dudas él mismo lo ha
dicho que está sentido como su mejor día
sobre la bicicleta ha dado las gracias a
su equipo a su familia a sus amigos
porque se dudaba de que podría llegar a
hacer rencor en el pool después de tan
grave accidente y hoy lo ha hecho a lo
grande atacado a 28 kilómetros de meta
en el call de la red un gol que tiene
rampas de hasta el 13% que es la gran
clave en esta carrera y ha dado un
ataque muy duro yo pensaba viendo la
carrera que igual no aguantaba hasta el
final
de ahí a la meta nadie ha sido capaz de
alcanzar al rencor en el pool que
necesitaba además distanciarse de sus
compañeros ciclistas porque no es un
ciclista con un gran sprint su principal
baza son estos ataques fuertes y es un
gran contrarrelojista que consigue
mantener las distancias en terreno más
llano pero de verdad ha sido muy bonito
ver arrancó bien el pool que ha llorado
en meta y se ha notado que tenía muchas
ganas de resarcirse de lo que ha pasado
en estos dos últimos años con respecto
al resto de ciclistas pues hemos visto
algo muy dispar ha habido un triplete
belga algo muy importante para los
belgas en esta carrera que se disputaba
en su casa y se ha visto también la
figura de mikel landa que ha estado
atacando ha sido quizás entre los
favoritos quien ha desatado todos los
ataques está preparándose en mikel landa
al espanyol para el giro de italia y ha
habido un punto negativo en la carrera a
60 kilómetros de meta ha habido una
montonera ha habido una caída muy grave
de la que ha salido muy mal parado el
ciclista francés julian a la philippe el
campeón del mundo que según el parte
médico que ha dado su equipo tiene
fractura de omóplato dos costillas rotas
y un pulmón perforado recuerda casi a la
caída rené pool habrá que ver cómo se
recupera el campeón del mundo y un punto
muy positivo para otro francés romain
bardet que cuando ha visto cómo estaba
su compañero su compatriota ha ido a
ayudarle